bourru que les anges la polémique n'en
finit plus d'enfler depuis quelques
semaines plusieurs candidates de
l'émission les anges dénonce le
harcèlement et les violences qu'elles
ont subies dans le programme diffusé sur
nrj12 nova ce qu'elle nous avait dit
qu'on va laisser franchement les mecs
ils n'en peuvent plus des dates vous
prendre une geek les trois d'entre elles
en gênera niayes natanya venait
témoigner en exclusivité sur notre
plateau elles ont notamment dénoncé la
violence de certains candidats
aucun détail qui est spécialisée dans
leur scellement donc envers les femmes
s'est approché de moi en disant j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] de la production tu vas
voir elle met aussi en cause la
responsabilité de la production à
l'origine de coups de pression pour
créer des séquences pas nous sortir des
ternes du genre bah si t'es pas prêt à
le faire il ya des mines cv sur la table
mais plus un problème encore elles nous
ont révélé la présence de drogue sur les
tournages la production le sait elle est
freinée par la production
ces nouvelles déclarations pourraient
venir compromettre fortement la
diffusion de l'émission ce soir trois
nouveaux candidats ont voulu donner un
droit de réponse qu'il s'agit de raphaël
tiffany et maïssane ils vont nous donner
leurs versions
merci à vous trois dette la merci max
and merci vous êtes candidate de
télé-réalité roues sont dessinés psy
merci à tiffany c'est la copine de rafah
les candidats de télé réalité aussi
merci raphaël candidats de télé-réalité
raphaël qui était déjà venu nous voir et
qui est pris pour cible par angèle
notamment dans cette affaire alors hier
on a écouté la version des trois jeunes
filles qui s'exprime et extrêmement bien
qui nous ont raconté l'histoire
aujourd'hui on aimerait avoir votre
version et c'est tout à fait normal
d'avoir votre version aujourd'hui
raphaël
oui donc vous vous est pris pour cible
dans cette affaire qu'est ce que vous
dites sur le harcèlement dont on a parlé
dans cette émission
et s'il reste que pour vous c c c c si
vous dites c'est des inepties ou est-ce
que vous ressentez annonce alors cessé d
inepties après du harcèlement c'est un
mot qui est très fort évidemment il ya
des querelles entre candidats on le voit
à l'antenne voilà il ya beaucoup de
turenne maintenant dire que c'est du
harcèlement je suis je ne pense pas non
non d'accord j'ai quoi sceller pour vous
c'est quoi ces les bruins et des cd des
taquineries mais aujourd'hui c'est ce
que vous pouvez retrouver partout dans
la rue sur une situation
d'automobilistes osé dans les écoles il
ya des querelles tout
ne s'entend pas forcément on
s'embrouille oui évidemment les uns des
violences aussi parce que mais on nous a
dit qu'on a une qui a failli prendre un
we are coûte moins de gueule et on a une
voix là qui a pris voilà c'était oui on
vous a reproché aussi d'avoir étranglé
une jeune fille et vous l'auriez reconnu
dans une terre alors je vous explique ça
à l'époque c'était ma compagne j'avais
18 ans je n'ai pas être anglais
effectivement c'est vrai qu'il a
travaillé par le coup d'accord c'est
alors c'est pas quelque chose à faire je
vous dis pas maintenant j'avais 18 ans
et je l'aï attrapée par le cou parce
qu'elle m'a traitée de d'un nom d'oiseau
d'algues ans devant et des raisons 50
personnes ans et pas une ride
ça c'est sûr et certain mais j'avais 18
ans ça m'est arrivé qu'une seule fois
maintenant je mets au défi n'importe qui
doute d'accord de trouver quelque chose
alors oui j'ai eu un tort j'ai eu 18 ans
je dis pas que c'est mais c'est
pardonnable jusque voilà j'étais un peu
plus jeune est un peu plus bête j'ai
beaucoup plus raphaël oui dans l'
enquête que j'ai fait et en recueillant
des témoignages il est quand même avéré
que vous êtes protégé surprotégé par la
production et que la production selon
des témoignages que j'ai vous inciterait
même à faire acte d'harcèlement de
provocation pour que les lots avec les
plombs alors je c'est une question que
je vous pose d'accord est ce que c'est
vrai et je pars je vais vous répondre
tout ça va laisser leur répondre vous
êtes journaliste
oui oui d'accord alors fait très bien
votre travail s'il vous plaît parce que
en aucun cas d'accord en aucun cas que
je le dis bien ici la production me
demande d'harceler des gens d'accord et
en aucun cas moi d'accord j'accepterai
si on me demandait d'harceler des gens
donc c'est très important de bien faire
son boulot parce que c'est votre métier
aujourd'hui de relater les faits et de
dire si oui ou non c'est vrai faites
très bien votre avis parce que c'est un
sujet très sensible aujourd'hui de
harcèlement d'accord et moi en aucun cas
je me serais permis d'harceler une femme
alors oui nicolas alors attendez qu
est-ce que vous escomptez le harcèlement
parce que moi j'ai été admis à présenter
une enquête
hélas est ce que je peux vous dire c'est
quand je vois un homme qu'il ya une
femme en jupe d'aller mettre un short et
l'a menacée c'est du harcèlement
d'accord mais vous vous parlez de quoi
je parle de votre comportement en
général il ya quand même des images qui
passent sur votre comportement
le harcèlement c'est du harcèlement donc
de temps en temps on lui a seulement
parlé de quelle image vous parle je
parle de rang en règle générale dans
l'est dans l'est
vous avez vu dans les angles exactement
la raison jouer mais l'était pas non
plus je n'ai pas non plus
vous accusez au caire 6 7 5 6 7 ou 8 mai
mais vous savez très bien de quoi je
parle un moment donné il ya une vidéo où
il ya une jeune fille qui est en quête
enquête en jupe et vous être été
quasiment de pub parce qu'elle est en
jupe longue bêtise je vous explosez des
bêtises on la remercie parce que c'est
ma copine à l'époque alors attendez mais
si j'ai pas envie qu'elle se mette en
jeu
à cette époque on va faire près d'accord
et vous allez regarder mais attendait
qu'ils vous regardent vous avez des
valeurs mais il ya les musulmans à
chacun ses valeurs et à chacun ses
principes d'accord avec toi on est
d'accord un jour vous c'était une copine
un moyen l'époque c'est ma copine elle
va voir un producteur d'accord faut
remettre dans le contexte qu'elle va
voir un producteur de chant je suis noir
s'il te plaît ne met pas cette jupe
moi je préfère que tu mettes important
pour y aller est-ce que c'est du
harcèlement resto ou considérer ça comme
tu dis mais sinon c'est très intéressant
ce que tu dis nicolas ces images ont été
diffusées on voit la dette ici en 2015
qu'est ce qui passait par là depuis mis
tous à l'époque les anges c'est un
carton ça faisait huit cent mille
téléspectateurs choqués parce que ça ça
n'est pas vu par du harcèlement comme du
harcèlement
c'est perçu comme une jalousie comme il
peut y en avoir dans plein de couple au
bout d'un moment j'ai l'impression qu'on
efface unique dans cette histoire à des
gens qui crachent dans la soupe qui
veulent tout faire annuler sous prétexte
de de harcèlement alors qu'ils savent
très bien qu'ils participent à des
émissions qui sont sulfureuse
on sait qu'il ya des clashs on sait que
parfois oui oui à de la drogue et que
c'est aussi les candidats qu'ils
l'apportent on sait qu'il ya des
embrouilles
on sait que l'on force les candidats se
mettre en couple oui parce que c'est une
émission de télé-réalité n'y a rien
d'autre à montrer donc faut arrêter
d'être en revanche on en voit remettre
un couple ou pas maichan maman j'en suis
la preuve vivante je me suis rarement
mis en couple sur mes émissions et à un
moment donné on fait une émission télé
ralité en sachant pertinemment nous on
est en train de candidats téléralité
maintenant on est des professionnels on
sait très bien que pour qu'une télé
ralité soir regardez c'est du
divertissement
il faut qu'ils aient des histoires de
coeur il faut qu'ils aient des disputes
donc on vous a jamais pour vous aussi
jamais forcé de faire quoi que ce soit
on n'est pas prisonnier de la production
on a droit de faire ce qu'on veut si
demain on a envie de partir parce que ça
ne nous plaît pas on peut et bien
entendu des histoires ils ont nos
passeports et tout mais pas du tout
demain
accessible à plus de maintenant ils ont
nos passeports mais si je le veux mais
je levais si je le veux je veux je
quitte le prochain alors il ya un truc
qui a fait énormément parler aussi
c'est l'alcool voilà yann alcool oui
comme je voulais dire sur le plateau il
ya un verre d'alcool par soir par contre
il a maintenant attendez le canada qui
va être ouvert mais n'ont aucun avec son
complexe attend effectivement la
production donne un verre aux candidats
parfois ça c'est inadmissible
ensuite s'est désolé ensuite mais
effectivement il ya des candidats à
faire entrer de l'alcool dont secours de
programmateurs balisé mais il fermeture
je ferme les yeux il ya des gens alors
je vais vous dire pour e.on et des
responsables en il y en a on a entre 25
et 30 ans non mais on est responsable
ils veulent pas ils veulent ni n'ont pas
envie de fouiller nos valises
maintenant oui il ya eu des magnums dans
des valises des candidats beaucoup mais
d'amis qui a eu il ya eu des cas il y
avait bien et il ya de tout non mais
vous le dites moi c'est alors il ya de
la drogue mais alors encore une fois il
ya de la drogue
non c'est parce que je t'ai dit non non
c'est exactement le même discours que
j'ai eu la dernière fois qu'il est venu
sur ce plateau d'accord et peut-être qui
a deux lacs de la drogue c'est possible
d'accord moi je vous rien n'a changé à
moi je donne un cheveu à m'envoyer un
email
j'ai jamais vous on n'a pas dit de grand
baie mais voilà vous dit actuellement il
ya des gens certainement qui à la
rentrée de la cour dans tout corps des
huit fois non mais finalement mon
cordonnier
je connais très bien il a fait ma copie
la semaine dernière c'est pourquoi tu
lis comme des bananes à venir mais non
mais non mais non parce que non je vous
dis la vérité
il ya énormément de jeunes qui regardent
et tout est mis dans une situation d
enduit d'émissions télé réalité vous
êtes filmés
mais on peut pas faire rentrer des
stupéfiants mais c'est l'émission il
s'est complètement condamnable mais un
câlin moi j'incite aussi puisque
visiblement parle de harcèlement mais on
va parler de drogue moi j'incite à
quiconque qui a vécu des heures
seulement d'accord ou qui a vu quelqu'un
prendre de la drogue devant lui allait
porter plainte
il ya un vrai must j'ai une question à
poser répondez-moi pour la wii - est-ce
que vous avez déjà vu un candidat même
si ça n'est pas été amené par la prod
prendre de la drogue dans une décennie
alors je vais je vais besoin en était
j'ai jamais vu deux candidats de prendre
de cocaïne effectivement ça m'est arrivé
de voir un candidat fumer un joint sur
le corps mais d'accord voilà vous en
voulez la vraie vérité
moi je je je je vous le disais ça fait
dix ans alors j'ai je suis pas un mec
parfait loin de là mais ça fait dix ans
depuis que suis dans la qualité que je
me bagarre contre la cocaïne d'accord ça
fait dix ans que si je vois un candidat
de télé réalité
donc vous n'avez rien ou quoi non si je
m'en balance et vous avec des si on
refait le monde
si je vois un candidat d'accord je le
dis à la production si je vois j'ai
aucun problème avec ça mekkaoui bernard
montiel qui cherche la tête que ça non
je sa tête je dis vous avez posé la
bonne question mais ici si si si il en a
vu vous avez forcément vu non alors la
phrase que j'ai dit oui j'ai déjà vu
wish it
d'accord il est aussitôt madelin compris
le joint oil avait dit mais j'ai jamais
vu cocaïne devant mais d'accor gilles
verdez la différence de discours en
criant aujourd'hui est incroyable hier
on gèle affirmait oui que la production
des anges fourni de la drogue donc
helmand selon vous alors alors en tout
cas pirates lb mais bien sûr qu'elles
vont aller pourquoi mentir et vous êtes
journaliste oui vous allez faire une
enquête
oui vous avez entendu quelques parties
reculé que ça arrive et bah oui soyons
la bouche d'angelina apparente et non
méritée pour un métier rendell non à mon
père et à moi c'est vraiment sur ta
tombe et laisse passer à côté son
aventure donc armé mais pour voir les
trois m'en tirer quoi taper mais non non
non attendez si après ça c'est un
discours propre à chacun moi si vous
êtes journaliste
votre métier c'est quand même de voir et
d'en
d'essayer d'avoir vraiment les tenants
et les aboutissants d'une histoire c'est
ça votre médiation
votre témoignage de dire qu'il est
complètement faux sur l'altercation qui
a pu se passer en ou raphaël aujourd'hui
mois et angel s'est complètement
peut-être parler du harceleur papa lé là
d'ailleurs il était matériellement à
tout accord maintenant je vais
m'expliquer ça fait nous on n'a pas pris
une fois la parole sur les réseaux
sociaux
oui d'accord ni ma femme ni moins
d'accord ça fait dix quinze jours que
j'entends que j'aurais été violent que
j'aurais été que je leur ai harcelés
d'accord je vais vous dire ça fait dix
ou quinze jours qu'on a pris un avocat
10 ou quatre jours que notre avocat nous
demande de se taire
on a demandé à la production par le
biais de notre avocat les images de 19h
à minuit de ce qui s'est passé lors de
cette soirée pour justement prouvé que
je suis pas en tort maintenant
malheureusement il ya un tribunal
aujourd'hui qui est médiatique sur alla
donc syrie beaucoup plus rapide
bien sûr un tribunal aux coupures aux
teintes histoire là enfin en tête mais
on le verra au niveau du procès qui va
prendre plus de temps
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on vient
ici parce que c'est un tribunal
médiatique mais vous verrez que if any
oui quand vous entendez ça ce qu'on dit
sur votre amoureux mais ça vous pèse ça
ne connaissez vous le reconnaissez pas
dans les descriptions qui ont fait de
lui mais jamais de la vie moi je vis
avec ça fait deux ans et demi qu'on est
ensemble à aucun moment c'est un homme
violent quand je vois angel ce qu'elle a
fait sur les réseaux sociaux moi je vais
vous dire elle à hapoël a amené l
appeler à la haine
aujourd'hui je me fais menacé
aujourd'hui je suis une femme battue
vous rendez compte des propos je suis
une femme battue ça me dire qu'il me bat
je reçois des messages tous les jours
des menaces de la haine c'est ce qu'elle
a fait les petits jeunes qui nous
soutiennent sur les réseaux qui ont des
comptes fans se sont menacés et harcelés
ils ont 12 13 ans et jean donc ça allait
beaucoup trop loin et elle a fait du
sybille du cyber harcèlement
elle parle d'harcèlement allait porter
plainte mais bien celles des pays jugés
on n'a pas attendre c'est pour ça qu'on
n'a pas parlé sur les socios accord
découverts près rennes je suis une
histoire une [ __ ] d'accord qui a été à
la retraite
je suis quelqu'un qui bat sa femme j'ai
couché avec la directrice générale soit
disant de la production ça va beaucoup
trop loin
je suis en pleine tous je sens que vous
avez presque les larmes aux yeux quand
vous entendez peu près ce calme parce
que c'est horrible séjourne à une
famille ses parents on a des parents des
soeurs des frères vous rendez compte
c'est nomme de barraute vos parents vos
mets mes parents ils sont devant la télé
les embrasse d'ailleurs mais c'est très
difficile pour nous voir et ils disent
et on parle pas de mon fils ça quand on
dort mais mais mais s'il vous plaît je
veux ensuite lié à un moment donné soyez
juste essayé moi je voulais avoir passé
pas à vous que je parle métier à tous
s'il vous plaît essayez de voir plus
loin que le bout de votre nez arrêtez
les médias c'est les les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui c'est en train de tuer le
monde est arrivé les réseaux sociaux et
bien sûr et attention un problème c'est
la vérifient pas les écouter je vais
vous dire très sincèrement c'est un
engrenage
c'est la vérité moi je fais de la télé
je vais prendre mon argent et j'ai envie
de dire et je rentre chez moi et ça
s'arrête là j'oublie tout ce qui s'est
passé là-bas parce que pour moi je vais
prendre avec moi dans ma tombe juste les
souvenirs mais pas les leurs et ça
n'existe pas c'est éphémère après neuf
mois je vous rentrez que des souvenirs
c'est tout je veux il faut savourer été
rappelés dans les télés pourquoi parce
que oui c'est un fort caractère qui n'a
pas la langue dans sa poche ça oui c'est
vrai c'est pour ça qu'il a toujours été
rappelé et il dit parfois parce que tout
haut ce que les gens pensent tout bas je
viens en aucun jeu convient violent donc
alors la drogue oui mais de cannabis pas
de pas de coke et moi j'ai jamais vu je
n'ai jamais voilà l'alcool oui ce sont
les candidats qui l'amène au harcèlement
vous dit non c'est le seul avec
l'amiante voilà ça fait mal juste
comprendre parce que la vérité mais
voilà les quelque part entre vous et les
voilà est-ce que tout n'est pas blanc
tous les ballons on est parfaitement
d'accord et je suis bien placé pour le
connais très bien et elle a été
maintenant jamais comprendre
il ya une question se pose et à qui
profite le crime pourquoi ces trois
personnes qui étaient là et voilà on
était assez clair elle s'envole à la
production c'est assez organisés et ont
franchement à nice coke était plutôt
convaincant c'est ça je ne sais pas qui
a raison je vous le dis donc
est ce que c'est de l'affabulation total
qu'elles sont des preuves a parlé
écoutez c'est la contraception pas
contre eux mais plus la prononcer mais
juste beaucoup mais moi je suis pas et
alors je vais vous dire je suis pas
l'avocat de la production nous on n'est
pas venue ici pour parler c'est déjà le
terrain alors il vous je les fais moi la
production il ne voulait pas qu'on
vienne ici je vous dis d'accord il ya
tout le monde nous a demandé de
permission bête parce que je trouve que
ce soir c'était très important mais il
était déprimé parce qu'il est là pour la
production
moi je suis là pour moi vous comprenez
ce que je veux dire je suis pas je vais
pas faire deux débats ça m'énerve pas
moi la production j'en ai rien merci
même temps de calan voilà j'en ai rien à
ses volets c'est vous les cibles mais là
sinon chez moi attendez ce qu'elle a dit
hier c'est j'ai été la cible de ce
qu'elle a dit oui
donc je viens défendre pour ce qui est
des histoires de drogue et tout ce qui
s'ensuit vis-à-vis de la production je
ne me sens pas visé
est-ce que je vais juste j'aimerais
savoir l on parle également de
prostitution tiffany maïssane est ce
qu'est ce que vous répondez à sablé
honnêtement j'ai écouté un petit peu le
discours de natanya que je connais
absolument pas pour le coup
personnellement si demande l'arrêt dans
un casting et qu'on me demande de me
mettre un truc dans la chouchou donc je
sais pas quoi
non mais c'est d'être très honnêtement
je ne vais ni sur le programme ni je
refais une télé réalité mais hélas mais
je me demande si je me suis pas trompé
de porte contre jackie et michel et les
autres demain j'arrête dans un casting
on me demande t on pose des questions
aussi personnel et aussi déplacé mais ça
vous est jamais arrivé ça de très près
par intérim et en tant que femme on me
demandait à mon premier casting télé
même mais vous vous doutez bien que
jamais de la vie j'ai fait un bateau et
même pas de vous aimer s'entraîne il
faut demander ça c'est la prod pour moi
sur la prod qui vous a demandé ça et
nous devons nous demander d'argent tous
les fils normal vous le faites pas mais
est ce qu'on vous demande c'est ce que
la prod vous a demandé vous avez posé
cette question avait osé nous plaçons le
déposer dans la rue berri casting jamais
de ma vie je me serais rendu demain ça
n'est pas le club dorothée non plus les
anges on al impression qu attendu
si tu aimes enfants tôt le club dorothée
se met des god non c'est un autre qu'il
ya ya ya beau il ya beaucoup de
candidats qui qui qui pointe du site qui
se range en soit rien du tout moi
doivent c'est leur problème à temps
parce que pourquoi je vous dis l'alcool
parce que l'alcool
je vais vous dire la production et je
les accable pas mais la production est
de faire son travail celle ci produit
non mais je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que sous l'effet de
l'alcool sous l'emprise de l'alcool
c'est là qu'il peut y avoir des
débordements sur donc il peut y avoir
mine de rien la violence mais v et sous
l'effet du cannabis les bonnes vous
savez bien une vérité rebondissements
voilà non mais ça mais non merci
mais moi je vais vous dire sans rapport
à l'isolément que par angel elle dit
qu'elle a été isolée suite à cette
altercation pour sa sécurité parce que
on allait être violent tuent elles
moi j'ai envie de vous dire en fait elle
a été mise en isolement oui ou c'est
pourquoi parce qu'elle avait consommé
donc elle avait bu elle avait bu de
l'alcool et en tant que vous savez qu'on
est quand même assez on est employé
on est on est sûr si on a un contrat de
travail à partir du moment où on est en
état d'ébriété sur un le travail que
fait le défend par ailleurs il nous met
en isolement non pas pour ça c'est alors
oui pour sa sécurité muffat sécurité de
quoi il ya une piscine
il ya des escaliers il ya un balcon elle
était bourré je voulais dire et ça on a
des preuves et on a des preuves là les
moins de 21 ans des caméras tout y est
hier raphaël oui à fabrice sopoglian wii
qui expliquait hier que vous n'auriez
plus votre place dans le programme
vous réagissez à ça j'ai envie de lui
dire peut-être quand bien même après j'y
étais il n'y était pas qu'est ce qui est
plus légitime là dedans on vous en
voulez à la production si le 6 il vous
sort du programme
non mais pas du tout mais voilà j'ai
soixante dix huit ans non j'en voudrais
pas la production je veux dire il ya un
moment donné il ya une fin pour tous et
une fin pour tous d'accord - j'ai pas de
problème avec ça
ce qui me dérange c'est pas que jared
arrêter les anges d'arrêter a été arrêté
je vais vous dire j'habite dans un
patelin 77
je suis et mon chien ma femme et ça
s'arrête là moi je vais pas vivre à
dubaï avec les j'en ai rien à cirer tout
ça oui je pose je poste une photo tous
les sites où vous aviez vous auriez à
dire à votre famille ce soir raphaël cas
peut-être souffert de tout ce qui a été
bon mais que sait même pas temps à ma
famille ccm au téléspectateur fonctionne
sur les réfugiés juste envie de leur
dire s'il vous plaît soyez un peu
euh censé arrêter de vous acharner parce
que c'est facile derrière un téléphone
de s'acharner sur les plateformes
instagram twitter facebook
aujourd'hui on reste des êtres humains
j'ai un moment une maman j'ai une grande
soeur j'ai une femme j'ai une belle mère
d'accord et en aucun cas je lèverai la
main sur une femme et c'est la première
phrase d'accord que j'ai dit angel
arrête moi si je me trompe ou tiffany la
première phrase que je lui ai dit dans
notre altercation qui m'a dit oh là là
c'est violent je lui dis sachez une
chose je ne lève pas la main sur les
femmes alors on laisse toi ça de la tête
tout de suite et ça puisqu'on va aller
devant la justice et que nous avons
demandé les images et le son ça va être
prouvé que ces plans de ma voix pour
diffamation oui d'accord de ce qu'on
peut on va porter plainte pour préjudice
moral préjudice d'image diffamation la
procédure est en cours je vous dis
depuis quinze jours puisque sur les
réseaux sociaux ça a été un déferlement
de haine mais d'accord et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui et jeudi c'est clair et
net c'est la première et la dernière
fois qu'on viendra s'expliquer sur ce
sujet là on va pas prendre les réseaux
sociaux d'accord je fermerai entrer dans
la course au buzz n'a pas que ça à faire
nous on vient juste expliqué une fois et
après terminé on fera appel à la justice
un merci en tout cas être venu tous les
300 fois